...
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Bonsoir
et bienvenue dans "Audition
publique", tous les lundis à 19h30
sur LCP et Public Sénat.
Ce soir, notre invitée est Marlène
Schiappa, secrétaire d'Etat
chargée de l'Economie sociale et
solidaire et de la Vie
associative, conseillère régionale
d'Ile-de-France.
Au programme, Emmanuel Macron et
sa communication anxiogène sur les
possibles coupures de courant.
On parlera aussi de la réforme des
retraites.
Vous avez confirmé une possible
élection au suffrage universel à
Paris, est-ce sérieux?
Vous allez être interrogée sur les
débats les plus brûlants à
l'Assemblée nationale.
Nous verrons également jusqu'où
peut aller le rapprochement avec
Les Républicains.
Nous verrons les questions
d'actualité avec Vincent Roux.
On va parler de votre travail sur
les associations.
C'est aujourd'hui la journée
mondiale pour le bénévolat.
Est-il en crise?
Vous répondrez tout à l'heure.
Mais en introduction, je voulais
vous dire qu'on vous entend peu,
en tout cas, on vous entend moins
que sous le quinquennat précédent.
Est-ce que c'est parce que les
dossiers que vous traitez vous
exposent moins ou est-ce que c'est
parce que vous avez pris une forme
de recul par rapport au débat
public?
- Marlène Schiappa: Bonsoir.
Il y a plusieurs éléments.
Quand j'ai été nommée en 2017 pour
la première fois au gouvernement,
les Français me connaissaient peu.
J'avais besoin de me faire
connaître et de faire connaître
mes combats.
Quand on regarde les palmarès de
popularité des personnalités
politiques, je le dis modestement,
je suis restée la même personne.
Aujourd'hui, c'est ma sixième
année comme membre du
gouvernement.
J'aborde d'une manière différente
le système dans lequel nous
oeuvrons.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Il y a une
forme de maturation.
Une question un peu plus
politique.
Sur un sujet qui vous touche.
L'équipe de France est en quart de
finale.
Si elle poursuit son beau parcours
au Qatar, Emmanuel Macron, on
l'imagine, ira soutenir l'équipe
de France.
Est-ce qu'il doit avoir un
discours public assez clair sur
les valeurs, dans un pays qui
criminalise l'homosexualité?
Est-ce qu'il doit assumer cela
publiquement?
- Marlène Schiappa: En ce qui
concerne le football, j'ai vu avec
beaucoup de plaisir les prises de
position d'Antoine Griezmann.
On dit que les footballeurs ne
prennent pas assez position, mais
j'ai vu que plusieurs membres de
l'équipe de France ont pris des
positions pour la dépénalisation
de l'homosexualité.
Ensuite, le président de la
République a dit qu'il aurait
vocation à se rendre à des matchs
si l'équipe de France allait loin
dans la compétition.
C'est sa position.
La ligne du président Emmanuel
Macron sur la diplomatie, c'est
vraiment le dialogue bilatéral.
C'est ce qu'il a fait avec
différents chefs d'Etat.
Je pense à l'Iran, je pense à
Donald Trump quand il était
président des Etats-Unis.
Il a toujours dit que les
désaccords profonds se discutaient
des yeux dans les yeux, en face à
face.
C'est pour cela qu'il ne veut pas
couper la ligne diplomatique,
comme il le fait avec la Russie.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Quand on
lui a posé la question, il a dit
"spontanément" qu'il ne fallait
pas politiser le sport.
On a des relations économiques
importantes avec le Qatar.
C'était une réponse diplomatique?
- Marlène Schiappa: Quand je suis
arrivée en 2017, je pensais comme
beaucoup de Français que lorsqu'on
veut défendre les positions de la
France, il faut être vocal, il
faut faire des discours.
Mais j'ai appris, en menant la
diplomatie féministe, que parfois,
on fait mieux avancer des dossiers
en face à face.
Je sais que le président est ferme
et intransigeant sur les droits
humains et sur les droits LGBT.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Vous ne
doutez pas qu'il va le dire aux
autorités du Qatar quand il ira.
- Marlène Schiappa: Ce n'est pas à
moi de dire au président ce qu'il
doit faire, mais je suis
convaincue qu'il porte cette
question des droits humains en
tête-à-tête dès qu'il voit un chef
d'Etat.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Vous
faites confiance à Emmanuel
Macron.
Ca vous fait réagir
personnellement, ce qui se passe
au Qatar pour les homosexuels?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je me réjouis
qu'on ait créé une fonction
d'ambassadeur LGBT.
Ce dernier a été nommé par le
président de la République pour
porter le sujet de la
dépénalisation de l'homosexualité
dans tous les pays du monde, sans
aucune exception.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Brigitte
Boucher et Tâm Tran Huy sont
arrivées.
On commence avec un sujet chaud.
- Brigitte Boucher: C'est le sujet
des retraites.
Pourquoi braquer les syndicats
d'emblée sur l'âge de départ à la
retraite?
- Marlène Schiappa: Il y a une
forme de consensus aujourd'hui
dans le champ politique, dans le
camp républicain, si l'on peut
dire, sur la nécessité de mener la
réforme des retraites.
Elisabeth Borne a dit qu'elle
voulait sauver le système de
retraite par répartition.
C'est ce qui me tient à coeur.
Il faut sauver notre système par
répartition avec une solidarité
entre les générations.
C'est ce système qui est en péril.
Dans le système actuel des
retraites, il y a des inégalités.
Il y a des personnes, notamment
des femmes, qui ont eu des
carrières hachées et qui se
retrouvent sous le seuil de
pauvreté à la retraite.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Le PS et
les Verts ne veulent pas ce
décalage de l'âge de départ.
Les Français y sont
majoritairement opposés.
Laurent Berger dit qu'il n'y a
aucune avancée sociale dans les
négociations.
Est-ce que vous n'êtes pas seuls
contre tous?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je dis à ces
personnes qu'il faut faire des
propositions.
La question des retraites est une
question qui n'est pas seulement
technique, mais aussi sociale.
Elisabeth Borne dit que pour elle,
le minimum des pensions de
retraite serait de 1200 euros.
C'est même au-delà de ce que nous
avions proposé.
Il y a donc du dialogue social.
La proposition de loi n'est pas
ficelée.
Elle n'a pas encore été présentée
en Conseil des ministres.
Il y a une discussion.
Dans ces cas-là, il faut faire des
propositions.
S'il y a des syndicats qui ne
veulent pas toucher à l'âge, ils
doivent faire des propositions
pour expliquer comment on arrive à
un système à l'équilibre sans
toucher à la durée du travail.
On va évoquer aussi la question
des régimes spéciaux.
On ne peut pas rester dans ce
système qui pénalise aujourd'hui,
notamment des femmes.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Le
président borde pas mal la
négociation.
Il a dit qu'il ne fallait pas
toucher au montant des pensions ni
aux cotisations.
On ne peut donc toucher qu'à l'âge
légal.
- Marlène Schiappa: Le président
avait annoncé qu'il ferait une
réforme des retraites.
On ne peut pas lui reprocher de
faire ce qu'il s'était engagé à
faire.
- Brigitte Boucher: Est-ce qu'il y
a une marge de négociation pour le
gouvernement?
- Marlène Schiappa: Le dernier mot
revient aux parlementaires.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Votre
téléphone sonne.
Si ce n'est pas une urgence, je
vous demande de le mettre en mode
avion.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je disais
qu'il y aura un débat
parlementaire et un débat avec les
syndicats et les représentants du
patronat.
- Brigitte Boucher: La Première
ministre doit dévoiler ses
arbitrages en décembre.
Est-ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
Noël de grèves?
- Marlène Schiappa: Nous sommes
dans des temps qui sont
difficiles.
Il y a l'inflation, la guerre en
Ukraine, des perspectives
difficiles.
Les Français ont besoin de se
retrouver en famille et de
profiter des fêtes de famille.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Que dites-vous aux
syndicats qui parlent d'une
riposte totale?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je ne remets
pas en question le droit de grève.
Mais nous parlons de grève par
anticipation.
J'invite chacun à la vertu du
dialogue social plutôt que
d'annoncer d'emblée qu'on va faire
grève.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Une grande
entreprise comme la SNCF qui
pénalise beaucoup de Français,
comme lors du week-end dernier,
qu'en pensez-vous?
- Marlène Schiappa: C'est
extrêmement difficile.
J'ai confiance en le ministre des
Transports qui va tâcher de
trouver des solutions concrètes et
pragmatiques dans les meilleurs
délais possibles.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Ca ne vous
frappe pas qu'une grande
entreprise comme la SNCF puisse
faire ainsi une grève au débotté?
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous me
demandez si je suis étonnée qu'il
y ait des grèves en France?
Je ne suis pas étonnée.
Pour moi, le droit de grève est un
droit constitutionnel.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Vous ne le
condamnez pas?
- Marlène Schiappa: Il ne s'agit
pas de condamner la grève, il
s'agit de dire si on est d'accord
ou pas d'accord sur les questions
de fond.
Mais je suis profondément gênée
par le dévoiement du droit de
grève.
Ca s'appelle du chantage, de dire
qu'on va faire grève si la
négociation n'aboutit pas dans son
sens.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Le gouvernement
est prêt à tenir face à la rue?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je ne vais pas
moi-même rentrer dans un rapport
de force et dire qu'on ne cédera
rien.
Je pars du principe que le
dialogue va réussir.
Elisabeth Borne est une femme de
dialogue, tout son parcours le
montre.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: En quoi
est-ce un dévoiement du droit de
grève quand on dit non à l'âge de
65 ans qui est déjà sur la table?
- Marlène Schiappa: On nous dit
que si la négociation n'aboutit
pas, on va faire une grève
préventive.
On n'a pas encore déposé le projet
de loi.
En revanche, Elisabeth Borne, elle
a démontré dans tout son parcours
à quel point elle savait mener le
dialogue et avancer sur le
dialogue social.
Elle a été au ministère du Travail
et elle a porté des réformes
lourdes.
- Brigitte Boucher: Vous dites
qu'il faut dialoguer, ça veut dire
que vous excluez de passer par le
49-3?
- Marlène Schiappa: Notre volonté
est de mettre en oeuvre le projet
du président de la République, sur
lequel il a été élu.
Le président élu et la majorité
élue souhaitent mettre ce projet
en oeuvre et si nous ne le
faisions pas, les Français nous
reprocheraient le contraire.
- Brigitte Boucher: Vous espérez
que la droite vote cette réforme?
- Marlène Schiappa: Pas seulement
avec la droite.
Le Parti Socialiste a su aussi
mener des réformes ambitieuses.
On peut faire la liste de toutes
les réformes du quinquennat de
François Hollande que la gauche
aujourd'hui ne considère plus
comme vraiment de gauches.
- Brigitte Boucher: Et l'idée
d'une réforme sur les retraites?
- Marlène Schiappa: C'est un outil
qui est dans la main du président.
C'est à lui de dire s'il souhaite
faire un appel direct aux Français
sur un sujet comme sur un autre.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Est-ce que
ça aurait du sens?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je réponds à
la question que vous me posez sur
le sujet.
Mais il faut réfléchir à la façon
dont la question serait tournée.
Est-ce que ce serait sur l'âge?
Est-ce que ce serait sur le
principe d'une réforme?
Ca peut être un référendum à
plusieurs questions.
Mais à l'heure actuelle, ce n'est
pas sur la table.
- Tâm Tran Huy: La proposition de
loi de La France Insoumise pour
porter l'IVG dans la Constitution
a été majoritairement adopté à
l'Assemblée.
Aujourd'hui, elle est dans la main
des sénateurs.
Qu'avez-vous envie de dire aux
sénateurs?
Un référendum serait-il
nécessaire?
- Marlène Schiappa: On ne va pas
faire un référendum sur chaque
sujet.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Mais que
diriez-vous aux sénateurs, qui ont
rejeté à une courte majorité cette
proposition de loi?
- Marlène Schiappa: Il y a des
possibilités de réécriture.
C'est un sujet très sensible.
La question de l'écriture du
projet de loi est très sensible.
C'est pourquoi les députés de la
majorité ont eu des hésitations
sur leur soutien à la proposition
de loi.
La réécriture a été quasiment
totale et elle a permis de trouver
une forme de quasi consensus.
J'ai vu que même Marine Le Pen
souhaitait constitutionnaliser
l'ensemble de la loi Veil.
Je pense que le consensus est
assez large en France.
- Tâm Tran Huy: Bruno Retailleau,
le patron des sénateurs LR, est
fortement opposé.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je pense que
vous faites un lien habile entre
plusieurs informations.
Peut-être que Bruno Retailleau est
en train de se positionner
politiquement pour montrer qu'il
est plus à droite que la droite de
la droite en s'opposant à ce grand
projet qui fait consensus.
Avec la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale, nous étions à
l'inauguration du buste de Simone
Veil dans les jardins de
l'Assemblée nationale.
Elle a rappelé que ces grandes
transformations
de société finissent par être
consensuelles.
Aujourd'hui, je pense que personne
de sérieux ne songe à remettre en
France le droit des femmes à
avorter.
Au-delà du symbole, il y a une
question de mariage territorial.
Je suis originaire de la Corse.
Je sais qu'il y a des endroits où
il est difficile d'avoir un
rendez-vous avec un gynécologue
aujourd'hui en France.
Je pense que cette proposition de
loi est un très bon symbole, mais
il faut aussi avancer sur le
concret.
C'est la même chose pour
l'allongement des délais.
Car parfois, on tarde à trouver un
rendez-vous chez un gynécologue.
C'est la priorité.
C'est ce sur quoi travaille le
ministre de la Santé.
Il faut améliorer ces problèmes de
déserts médicaux.
- Brigitte Boucher: Emmanuel
Macron a donné une interview au
journal Le Parisien.
Il a été interrogé sur l'affaire
Quatennens.
Il dit qu'il n'est pas là pour
faire la police de la démocratie.
Vous en pensez quoi?
- Marlène Schiappa: Il est
président de la République.
Il est garant des institutions.
Ce n'est pas son rôle d'agir
là-dessus.
Je défends la séparation des
pouvoirs.
Ce n'est pas au président ni à un
ministre de choisir les
représentants du peuple.
Ma position de membre du
gouvernement, pas celle de Marlène
Schiappa, c'est de ne pas demander
la démission d'un parlementaire.
Pour autant, je suis évidemment
scandalisée par les faits et les
actes qu'Adrien Quatennens a
avoués.
Je suis aussi choquée par les
propos qui ont été tenus par les
ténors de La France Insoumise qui
ont fait le défilé dans les
chaînes de télévision pour
minimiser et pour dire qu'une
gifle isolée, ce n'est pas grave.
Une gifle, c'est un fait grave.
On a fait le Grenelle des
violences conjugales.
On dit qu'il faut partir dès la
première gifle.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Certains
appellent quand même à la nuance
et à la gradation des faits.
On ne peut pas comparer une gifle
avec des violences conjugales
beaucoup plus graves.
Vous l'entendez?
- Marlène Schiappa: Bien sûr qu'il
y a une gradation.
Dans toutes les lois, il y a des
gradations.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: C'est ce
que disait monsieur Bompard.
- Marlène Schiappa: Ce n'est pas
ça qu'il a dit.
Il a dit que c'était un fait
violent mais que ce n'était pas un
homme violent.
Dans ce champ lexical, Clémentine
Autain a dit encore récemment que
les hommes violents étaient aussi
"nos maris, nos camarades", à
soigner, ce qui est un discours
complètement incohérent avec ce
que disait avant La France
Insoumise.
Notamment quand les accusations
concernaient des personnes dans le
camp opposé.
J'appelle la justice à agir.
C'est à la justice de dire si
Adrien Quatennens est coupable ou
innocent.
J'appelle aussi au respect des
victimes.
On ne peut pas dire que l'écoute
doit se libérer et balayer de la
main une main courante.
- Tâm Tran Huy: L'Assemblée
nationale a voté la semaine
dernière contre l'avis du
gouvernement une proposition de
loi pour une juridiction
spécialisée contre les violences
intrafamiliales.
Pourquoi cette opposition de la
majorité?
Est-ce que ce n'est pas une
opposition de principe?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je vais faire
un rapprochement avec la question
de l'accès à l'IVG.
C'est une fausse bonne idée.
On peut regarder ce qui s'est
passé en Espagne.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Mais ça
fonctionne en Espagne.
- Marlène Schiappa: L'Espagne a
commencé en 2004.
Elle n'a pas fait seulement une
proposition de loi avec des juges
spécialisés.
Elle a fait en sorte qu'il y ait
un maillage territorial.
Si demain vous avez des tribunaux
spécialisés, aujourd'hui, la
justice française n'est pas en
mesure de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un tribunal par département ou
circonscription.
Ca veut dire que vous ne serez pas
jugé de la même manière selon que
vous habitez en Corse, à Marseille
ou à Lille.
C'est une inégalité d'accès à la
justice.
Je ne dis pas non aux tribunaux
spécialisés.
Je pense que c'est une proposition
qui se regarde.
Le garde des Sceaux est en train
d'étudier cette proposition pour
voir si cela apporterait un
bénéfice.
Je pense qu'il faut former toute
la chaîne de la justice à la
question des violences conjugales.
Il faut que tous les magistrats
soient formés à ces sujets.
Aujourd'hui, un magistrat est
formé aux droits civils, quelle
que soit sa juridiction.
C'est fondamental de faire avancer
les magistrats sur cela.
On a fait voter 5 lois en 5 ans
pour améliorer les droits des
femmes.
Il reste beaucoup à faire.
Aujourd'hui, il y a une
augmentation des chiffres, malgré
la baisse due au Covid.
On n'arrive pas encore à faire
baisser les chiffres dans la durée
mais on a réussi à les faire
baisser pendant le Covid.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Dans
quelques minutes, on va revenir
sur le dossier bénévolat.
Les vocations sont en baisse.
On rejoint tout de suite Vincent
Roux pour Le Figaro Live.
Vous avez regardé les centres
d'intérêt des lecteurs du Figaro.
Les pannes de courant,
franchement, c'est au top des
préoccupations.
*- Vincent Roux: C'est au top des
préoccupations des Français.
Est-ce que vous êtes sereine par
rapport à cette situation, Marlène
Schiappa?
- Marlène Schiappa: Il faut qu'on
réussisse à éviter les mouvements
de panique.
Je le dis parce que le
gouvernement a un plan qui a été
présenté et construit par les
collectivités et l'ensemble des
partenaires pour réussir à
diminuer notre consommation
d'électricité de 10%.
J'invite toutes les personnes qui
regardent cette émission à
installer sur leur téléphone la
météo de l'électricité.
*- Vincent Roux: Il y a une
rhétorique du gouvernement qui
vise à donner toujours des
conseils pratiques.
Mais nous avons fait un sondage
dans lequel on voit que 57% des
Français n'en peuvent plus, de
cette rhétorique.
Ils pensent que c'est d'abord et
avant tout à l'Etat de les
protéger dans cette situation.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je le
comprends.
Je vois les critiques qui disent
qu'il y a un Etat nounou qui vous
dit de vous laver les mains
pendant le Covid et d'éteindre la
lumière en quittant une pièce.
Mais il faut que chacun d'entre
nous soit attentif pour diminuer
sa consommation d'électricité.
C'est ce qui permettra de passer
le cap sans avoir de coupure.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Il y a une
forme de culpabilisation, quand
même.
On fait reposer le problème sur
les Français et leur discipline.
*- Vincent Roux: Beaucoup de
Français disent que c'est à l'Etat
d'agir.
- Marlène Schiappa: Le président
de la République a anticipé cette
question dès le mois de juillet.
Il a dit qu'on pouvait passer
l'hiver ensemble si on arrivait à
diminuer notre consommation de
10%.
L'idée est de demander des efforts
aux plus gros, les administrations
et les entreprises.
On réussira si chacun d'entre nous
surveille sa consommation
d'électricité.
Ce ne serait pas responsable de
dire aux gens qu'ils peuvent
consommer comme ils le souhaitent.
On veut anticiper.
*- Vincent Roux: Bon courage pour
convaincre les Français!
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Nous
sommes avec Yves Thréard,
directeur adjoint de la rédaction
du Figaro.
- Yves Thréard: Hier, l'ancien
président de la République,
Nicolas Sarkozy, était l'invité du
conseil représentatif des
institutions juives de France.
Il a dit qu'il fallait un accord
entre Les Républicains et le
pouvoir exécutif actuel.
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
ça?
- Marlène Schiappa: D'abord,
j'écoute ce que dit le président
Sarkozy.
Il n'y a pas tant d'anciens
présidents de la République qui
ont une parole au service de
l'intérêt général par les temps
qui courent.
Je l'écoute, mais je ne viens pas
de LR.
Je ne suis pas inquiète pour
l'avenir du parti.
- Yves Thréard: Vous cherchez une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale.
- Marlène Schiappa: Nous avons une
majorité.
- Yves Thréard: Elle est relative.
Vous ramez à coups de 49-3.
- Marlène Schiappa: Pour
l'instant, plusieurs ministres
réussissent à avoir des majorités
de projet.
S'il y a des parlementaires LR qui
veulent travailler avec nous, nous
y sommes évidemment ouverts.
Certains ont quitté le groupe LR
pour rejoindre Renaissance, par
exemple.
- Yves Thréard: Donc, pas d'accord
pour vous.
Ca ferait trop pencher votre
majorité à droite?
- Marlène Schiappa: Ce n'est pas à
moi de répondre sur les accords de
partis.
Nous avons également accueilli
Renaud Muselier.
Tous les talents de LR rejoignent
maintenant Renaissance.
- Yves Thréard: Le président
Sarkozy est allé chercher une
citation du président Pompidou
pour dire que c'était au plus fort
de tordre la main au plus faible.
Le président Pompidou aurait dit
ça.
Est-ce que vous encouragez votre
président de la République à
tordre la main aux autres?
- Marlène Schiappa: Le président
s'est engagé dès 2017 à élargir sa
majorité.
- Yves Thréard: Je vais m'y
prendre autrement...
En ce moment, il y a l'élection à
la présidence des Républicains.
Est-ce que vous estimez que ce
parti penche trop à droite?
- Marlène Schiappa: Qu'un parti de
droite défende des idées de
droite, ça ne me choque pas.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Mais il y
a plusieurs droites.
C'est un peu la droite dure.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je ne dis pas
ça.
Je suis toujours un peu triste
pour la démocratie quand des
partis qui ont été des grands
partis de gouvernement sont à la
ramasse, comme c'est le cas du
Parti Socialiste qui est
aujourd'hui la remorque de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon.
Il y a un processus interne à LR.
Ce n'est pas à moi d'arbitrer le
duel entre Bruno Retailleau et
Eric Ciotti.
- Yves Thréard: Vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure, vous êtes
corse.
Vous avez fait un détour par la
Sarthe et maintenant vous êtes à
Paris.
Vous habitez à Paris.
Vous vous êtes présentée à Paris.
Vous avez une idée, c'est de
réformer l'élection du maire de
Paris.
Actuellement, c'est une élection
au suffrage universel indirect.
Vous dites que maintenant, il faut
que cette élection se fasse au
suffrage universel direct,
c'est-à-dire que la population
élise son maire.
Quel est l'avenir de cette
ambition?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je suis
parisienne.
J'ai grandi dans le 13e, j'ai
habité dans le 16e.
Je considère que les Parisiens ont
le droit de choisir leur maire.
Nous avons une maire de Paris qui
est élue par le jeu des
arrondissements, par les
conseillers de Paris.
- Yves Thréard: C'est aussi le cas
à Lyon et à Marseille.
- Marlène Schiappa: C'est pour
cela qu'il faudrait élargir ce
projet aux grandes villes pour que
les Parisiens puissent avoir le
droit d'élire directement leur
maire.
Cela fait partie des pistes qui
sont étudiées.
J'ai eu à constater que c'était
une demande qui émanait aussi
d'élus de tous bords politiques.
Je pense que ça peut faire
sérieusement partie des pistes à
étudier.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: La
majorité à Paris dit que c'est du
tripatouillage.
- Yves Thréard: Quel sera le
cheminement de cette réforme?
Elle est portée par Gérald
Darmanin?
- Marlène Schiappa: C'est la
volonté de plusieurs élus.
Notamment Sylvain Maillard,
président de la fédération
Renaissance à Paris.
C'est la figure de proue de ce
projet, que je soutiens.
Le ministre de l'Intérieur est en
train de l'étudier, à la demande
des élus de Paris.
- Yves Thréard: Ca pourrait venir
quand?
- Marlène Schiappa: Pour
l'instant, il n'y a pas encore
d'arbitrage.
Je ne vais pas donner de
calendrier avant l'arbitrage.
Il faut d'abord consulter les
élus.
- Yves Thréard: Il y aura des
élections municipales à Paris en
2026.
Si vous me permettez, il y a du
monde au balcon.
- Marlène Schiappa: Il y a du
monde sur la corde à linge.
- Yves Thréard: On sait qu'il y a
deux personnes dans votre
formation politique qui se
verraient bien maire de Paris et
qui se disputent la candidature.
Il y a Gabriel Attal d'une part,
et d'autre part, il y a Clément
Beaune.
Ils sont tous les deux au
gouvernement.
Ils ont eu des mots pas tellement
agréables l'un envers l'autre.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je n'ai
entendu ni l'un ni l'autre
s'exprimer sur une candidature.
Pour l'instant, nous sommes très
soudés et nous avons beaucoup de
travail sur le collectif.
Gabriel Attal a beaucoup de
talent, Clément Beaune également.
- Yves Thréard: Clément Beaune dit
qu'il faut mettre Paris sous
tutelle et Gabriel Attal dit que
non, pas du tout.
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous savez, je
pense qu'on gagne toujours dans
l'unité.
Les dernières élections
municipales ont été extrêmement
compliquées pour la majorité à
Paris.
Donc je suis pour qu'on parle de
cette réforme du mode de scrutin
et qu'on s'organise dans notre
fédération à Paris, pour
travailler sur un projet avec un
candidat.
Il y a de la place pour tout le
monde.
Si les arrondissements restent
comme tels, il y a 17 maires
d'arrondissement qui doivent être
têtes de liste.
C'est une équipe qui doit être
soudée.
- Yves Thréard: Et vous, maire de
Paris c'est envisageable?
- Marlène Schiappa: Ce n'est pas
mon ambition.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Vous dites
donc qu'il faut un peu de patience
avant de manifester son désir de
candidature.
- Marlène Schiappa: J'ai beaucoup
de respect pour la trajectoire
politique de chacun mais c'est
important de rester unis tous
ensemble.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Merci
beaucoup, Yves Thréard.
C'est aujourd'hui la journée
mondiale du bénévolat.
C'est vrai qu'on observe une
petite crise.
15% de candidatures en moins sur
le bénévolat.
Est-ce que c'est une sonnette
d'alarme?
- Marlène Schiappa: On a commandé
une étude sur le panorama du
rapport des Français avec
l'engagement associatif pour
battre en brèche un certain nombre
d'idées reçues.
Il y a des personnes d'un certain
âge ou qui sont fragiles qui ne
sont plus retournées dans les
associations depuis le Covid.
Ce matin, nous avions une étape du
tour de France du bénévolat sur la
région Ile-de-France.
80 bénévoles font des ateliers
d'idées pour réfléchir à la
meilleure manière de faire venir
des bénévoles.
En cela, je pense que la solution
est la simplification
administrative.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Ca fait 30
ans qu'on entend ça, Marlène
Schiappa.
Comment on fait?
- Marlène Schiappa: On passe à un
guichet unique, à de la
dématérialisation.
Un guichet unique pour les
subventions, c'est beaucoup de
temps gagné.
Ca fait 6 ans que je suis au
gouvernement, ça fait 6 ans que je
vois les mêmes associations qui
doivent à chaque fois réexpliquer
qui elles sont et ce qu'elles
font.
Il faut des conventions
d'objectifs pluriannuels plutôt
que des appels à projets pour leur
permettre d'être sécurisées dans
leur budget.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: C'est une
réforme que vous êtes en train de
mettre en place.
Vous êtes en charge de la
Citoyenneté.
Est-ce que cette crise vous
inquiète?
- Marlène Schiappa: Non, car je
vois des Français très engagés.
Dans l'étude dont je vous parle,
près d'un Français sur deux se dit
engagé dans une association.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: C'est un
tissu dont on a absolument besoin.
- Marlène Schiappa: Tout à fait,
je salue les bénévoles qui se sont
engagés pendant le Covid pour
l'aide aux personnes âgées, l'aide
aux devoirs.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Le guichet
unique, c'est pour quand?
- Marlène Schiappa: Dans les mois
qui viennent, courant 2023.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Pour
l'établissement d'une association
et son renouvellement de demande
de subvention?
- Marlène Schiappa: Exactement.
Et que l'association n'ait pas
besoin de faire des dossiers dans
quatre différents ministères.
Il faut un dossier, un papier.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: On attend
les précisions sur cette question.
Arthur Delaporte, merci d'être
avec nous.
Vous êtes élu du Parti Socialiste,
dans le Calvados.
On va parler de la question de la
jeunesse et de la précarité.
- Arthur Delaporte: Je sais que
vous avez salué, sur votre
précédent mandat, certains jeunes
qui s'engageaient lors de la crise
du Covid.
Mais saluer l'engagement des
jeunes, ce n'est pas suffisant.
Il faut traiter le problème à la
racine.
Un étudiant sur deux n'arrive pas
à subvenir à ses besoins
alimentaires.
Pourquoi être revenu en arrière
sur le ticket à un euro pour tous
les étudiants?
- Marlène Schiappa: Nous ne sommes
pas revenus en arrière.
Il est toujours en vigueur.
C'est un engagement d'Emmanuel
Macron.
D'abord, les médailles ne sont pas
le résumé de la politique publique
menée par le gouvernement en
direction des jeunes.
C'est fondamental d'avoir cette
reconnaissance pour ceux qui n'en
demandent pas.
Vous auriez vu les jeunes qui sont
venus au ministère de l'Intérieur
pour la première fois de leur
vie...
J'étais avec la Première ministre
il y a deux ou trois semaines, et
auprès des banques alimentaires.
Nous avons débloqué un fonds de 60
millions d'euros pour faire en
sorte que les étudiants les plus
précaires puissent avoir accès à
une alimentation de qualité auprès
des banques alimentaires.
Il y a des jeunes qui sont dans
une situation de précarité et qui
n'ont pas de quoi se nourrir.
On a besoin d'être auprès d'eux.
C'est ce que nous faisons avec le
CROUS et le plafonnement des
loyers.
- Arthur Delaporte: Pourquoi vous
refusez la généralisation à un
euro pour tous les étudiants?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je suis en
train de vous répondre.
Il n'y a pas une seule jeunesse en
France.
Nous travaillons pour cette
jeunesse qui reste précarisée.
Il y a ce fonds de 60 millions
d'euros pour les banques
alimentaires.
Mais il y a aussi des étudiants
qui ne sont pas dans le besoin.
Certains ont suffisamment d'argent
eux-mêmes, ou leurs parents.
Nous voulons aider les plus
pauvres et ceux qui ont moins.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Il y a
suffisamment de bourses
aujourd'hui?
- Arthur Delaporte: 80% des jeunes
n'ont pas de bourse en France.
- Marlène Schiappa: Si vous saviez
par quoi je suis passée en tant
que jeune...
Vous n'êtes pas journaliste,
monsieur le député.
- Arthur Delaporte: Je suis là
pour vous poser des questions.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Ne parlez
pas tous les deux en même temps!
- Arthur Delaporte: Pourquoi
refuser la généralisation du repas
à un euro?
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous m'avez
d'abord posé la question de savoir
si j'étais au courant qu'il y
avait des étudiants précarisés.
Je vous dis que vous ne savez pas
par quoi je suis passée quand
j'étais jeune et étudiante.
Les questions dont vous parlez,
non seulement je les connais, mais
je les ai vécues.
J'ai eu des difficultés
financières quand j'étais jeune.
Je n'avais pas de bourse et on me
disait que mes parents n'avaient
qu'à m'aider.
Nous faisons en sorte que ces
jeunes puissent se loger avec le
plafonnement des loyers.
- Arthur Delaporte: Vous n'avez
pas augmenté les APL à hauteur de
l'inflation.
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous décalez
le débat.
Vous me demandez ce que nous
faisons, je vous réponds et vous
me parlez d'autre chose.
Ma réponse est simple.
- Arthur Delaporte: Je vous
demande pourquoi vous refusez la
demande des étudiants de
généraliser le repas à un euro.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: A cette
question, madame la ministre a
répondu que c'était parce que tous
les étudiants ne méritent pas de
bénéficier de cette aide.
Vous répondez qu'il y a quand même
80% des étudiants qui en ont
besoin.
Nous en sommes là.
- Marlène Schiappa: Passons à
autre chose.
Il y a un fonds de 60 millions
d'euros que nous avons lancé avec
la Première ministre.
J'ai répondu sur le plafonnement
des loyers et la question du
CROUS.
La ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur a mobilisé des crédits
pour que les jeunes puissent être
logés dans des dispositifs et
poursuivre leur étude sereinement.
- Arthur Delaporte: Nous n'avons
pas eu de réponse à notre question
à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
repas à un euro, c'était un
dispositif qui bénéficiait à tous,
notamment à ceux qui sont
au-dessus du seuil des bourses
mais qui ne vivent absolument pas
dans le luxe.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je vous ai
répondu sur la question des
banques alimentaires.
Il y a un fonds de 60 millions
d'euros.
- Arthur Delaporte: J'ai porté un
amendement pour permettre aux
bénévoles des Restos du Coeur
d'avoir un crédit d'impôt pour
pouvoir être aidés dans leur
bénévolat.
Cet amendement a été refusé par la
majorité.
Nous avons réussi à le faire voter
dans le projet de loi de finances
mais il n'a pas été retenu après
le 49-3.
Vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a une
inégalité parce que ceux qui n'ont
pas les moyens et qui sont
bénévoles n'ont pas d'avantages
fiscaux?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je vous
remercie de citer les Restos du
Coeur.
Ils sont numéro 1 dans le coeur
des Français pour les
associations.
Votre question rejoint le tour de
France du bénévolat dont une étape
avait lieu aujourd'hui au
ministère.
Je pense que sur la question de la
fiscalité associative, il y a
encore des progrès à faire.
On peut mettre sur la table la
manière de valoriser cet
engagement.
Par exemple, je porte la
validation des acquis de
l'expérience pour les bénévoles.
C'est une équivalence à un diplôme
pour les compétences qui ont été
acquises au sein d'une
association.
Je prends votre point et je
m'engage à étudier cette question
que vous évoquez.
Je reviendrai vers vous dès la fin
du tour de France du bénévolat,
avant le mois de juin.
- Arthur Delaporte: En tout cas,
j'ai porté cette demande au
Parlement et cela a été refusé par
vos collègues de la majorité.
- Marlène Schiappa: Ce n'est pas
le gouvernement qui vote.
Ce sont les députés de la nation.
- Arthur Delaporte: J'espère que
vous allez transmettre cela à
Gabriel Attal.
- Marlène Schiappa: Je vais le
transmettre à moi-même.
- Arthur Delaporte: On parlait de
la précarité étudiante, mais il y
a aussi plus largement une
précarité économique et une
précarité psychique.
Vous avez mis en place un plan
pour des consultations gratuites,
jusqu'à 8 d'une demi-heure.
Mais ce n'est absolument pas
suffisant.
Aujourd'hui, on manque de
psychologues.
Dans les pays voisins, il y a à
peu près 10 fois plus de psys pour
les étudiants.
C'est un sujet important quand on
sait qu'il y a presque un tiers
des étudiants qui déclarent avoir
des problèmes psychiques.
Il y a une association qui
s'implique dans la question de la
précarité psychique pour
l'accompagnement des jeunes, mais
le gouvernement doit agir et
recruter des psys à l'université.
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous avez
raison.
Je partage votre constat.
La place de la psychiatrie en
France, c'est un sujet qui a été
long et difficile à mettre en
place.
Nous avons levé le numerus clausus
avec Emmanuel Macron pour former
davantage de psychiatres, y
compris dans les lycées et les
universités.
On a parlé de la question du
Covid.
Le confinement a eu un impact
qu'on ne mesure pas encore
totalement sur les jeunes et les
étudiants.
Cette génération a perdu deux ans
de sa jeunesse pendant laquelle
elle ne pouvait pas sortir de chez
elle.
Le gouvernement fait tout ce qui
est en son pouvoir pour faire en
sorte de libérer cela mais cela
prend du temps de former des
psychiatres.
Les chèques ne sont peut-être pas
suffisants, mais c'est une
démarche inédite.
C'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement s'engage à financer
des consultations psys pour les
jeunes.
Pas seulement une consultation,
mais huit consultations!
On a besoin d'attirer des jeunes
pour qu'ils deviennent étudiants
en psychiatrie.
- Arthur Delaporte: Ca pose la
question du système de santé
universitaire.
Il faudrait une prise en charge à
la fac avec un accompagnement
gratuit.
- Marlène Schiappa: Nous avons une
pénurie de personnels de santé.
C'est vrai aussi pour les lycées.
Je suis une maman de lycéens, et
je vois qu'il n'y a pas
suffisamment de psys.
Il y a une question encore de
maillage territorial.
Ca rejoint ce que nous disions sur
les gynécologues tout à l'heure.
C'est également vrai pour les
femmes qui veulent avoir accès à
la contraception et qui n'ont pas
de rendez-vous chez le
gynécologue.
Ca devient très long dans certains
territoires pour avoir un médecin
traitant.
C'est pour cela que nous faisons
une action sur la santé avec
François Braun pour libérer du
temps médical et permettre à
chaque praticien d'avoir plus de
temps pour ses patients et pour
apporter un suivi de meilleure
qualité.
- Arthur Delaporte: J'aurais aimé
débattre sur la désertification
médicale.
Mais nous n'avons pas pu en
discuter à cause du 49-3.
Ce qu'on proposait, c'était des
obligations d'installation des
médecins pour mieux répartir
l'offre de santé.
Malheureusement, le gouvernement a
refusé d'avoir ce débat avec nous.
- Marlène Schiappa: Vous ne pouvez
pas blâmer le fait qu'il y ait une
consultation avec le CNR.
L'urgence est là, nous sommes
nombreux à le dire, oui.
L'urgence était déjà là sous
Hollande.
Ce problème de la désertification
médicale, il a des conséquences
graves.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Vous
pensez que la solution n'est pas
l'obligation d'installation?
- Marlène Schiappa: Non.
Il faut consulter le CNR.
Il faut savoir ce que les
soignants souhaitent.
Et on ne forme pas un médecin ou
un psychiatre en claquant des
doigts.
Ce que nous disent aujourd'hui les
soignants, c'est que l'obligation
d'installation n'est pas une
solution pérenne et efficace.
Si on avait traité ce sujet quand
François Hollande était président
de la République, on n'en serait
pas là.
Vous connaissez la durée de
formation pour un médecin.
Peut-être que François Hollande
aurait dû écouter les élus locaux.
Vous n'étiez pas ministre de la
Santé, mais vous étiez avec
François Hollande.
Aujourd'hui, c'est Emmanuel Macron
qui apporte des solutions.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Merci,
Arthur Delaporte, d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui.
C'était un peu chaud mais
intéressant.
Vincent Roux, vous êtes revenu
avec une question importante.
Une grande question de réflexion.
*- Vincent Roux: A la fin de la
semaine, il va y avoir
l'installation d'une convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie.
Est-ce qu'il va y avoir vraiment
un débat sur la question ou bien
est-ce que les jeux sont faits et
on doit se préparer à un texte qui
va légaliser la fin de vie?
- Marlène Schiappa: Le président
de la République souhaite vraiment
l'unité de notre pays.
A chaque fois que le pays est
divisé, à chaque fois qu'on touche
à une question taboue comme la
mort, la douleur, la fin de vie,
il veut que le sujet nous réunisse
et non pas qu'il nous fracture.
L'idée est donc de ne pas en faire
un drapeau ou une victoire
politique mais, au contraire,
d'apporter des réponses à des
situations de grandes souffrances
qui existent aujourd'hui.
Il faut que chacun puisse avoir
voix au chapitre.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Vous avez
votre réponse, Vincent?
*- Vincent Roux: Oui.
Il y a un problème qui ressort
quand même à chaque débat sur
cette question, puisque ça fait 20
ans que c'est dans le débat.
C'est la question des soins
palliatifs.
Il y a un engagement légal d'avoir
dans tous les départements des
unités permanentes de soins
palliatifs.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas plutôt ça,
la priorité?
- Marlène Schiappa: Je ne veux pas
préempter le débat.
Bien sûr, ça fait partie des
dispositions.
Nous avons eu ce débat lors de la
loi Leonetti.
Il y a des dispositifs qui
existent.
Notamment la possibilité de donner
sa volonté à un proche, quel que
soit cette volonté, que ce soit de
pouvoir rester en soins palliatifs
ou le contraire.
Ce sont des choix personnels qui
sont tous parfaitement
respectables.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: En Iran,
les manifestants ne plient pas.
Les mollahs ont annoncé abolir la
police des moeurs mais la
population n'y croit pas.
Le mouvement a débuté le 16
septembre.
Il y a eu 300 morts, au moins.
Que vous inspire cette révolution?
- Marlène Schiappa: Beaucoup de
respect pour le courage immense
des femmes iraniennes et des
hommes qui les soutiennent.
La France les soutient.
Le président de la République a
d'ailleurs reçu personnellement à
l'Elysée des femmes qui sont les
leaders de cette révolution
iranienne.
Nous sommes à leur côté.
- Elizabeth Martichoux: Merci
d'avoir été notre invitée.
On se retrouve la semaine
prochaine.